when thinking of cape town you might
imagine
white sand beaches whiny states and the
imposing table mountain
picture perfect isn't it but this
beautiful city
is one of the most dangerous in the
world and it has the highest murder rate
in south africa
now since january more than 2 000 people
have been murdered
most murders and other types of violent
crime are linked to gang activity in the
cape flats the flats as they are called
locally
are an area of densely packed townships
on the outskirts of cape town
we're about to meet one man from the
cape flats
who's turned away from gangsterism and
hoping to forge
a new life for himself
for tabisso lande gardening has recently
become
a calling he is making money and
feels good and safe while doing it
that's something he can't say about his
previous life as a gang member
it cost him six months in prison and
almost his life
i got shot in the face through my nose
through my head and i got shot six times
on my final point
but god willingly i survived but my
mother died
and and if you if you want to
ask me about crime now that is me for
example
an example of what crime is and what
crime does
you know to people so crime is very
right here and
and the due to unemployment the project
violence prevention through
urban upgrading in the kailicha township
hopes to offer an
alternative to people like lande it's
partly financed by german development
funds
the garden is not only a source of food
and income for the gardeners the
vegetables are also cooked in the
kitchen over there
and then served to the kids in the
kindergarten
next door
[Music]
offering childcare leisure activities
internet access electricity and water
the center has become an important
meeting point for residents
the murder rate in this part of the
township has fallen in recent years
those involved in the project say it's
reducing violence in the neighborhood
it prevents it a lot because if you look
around the
area just where we are at the active box
it's very active
there's mothers there's gardeners active
there's children so just the visibility
of people
we've got an approach called safety
three activation so it's not really
having policing
and soldiers walking around but the
presence of communities
enable everybody to walk across without
feeling scared
in many of cape town's townships that's
not possible since july the military has
been patrolling the so-called cape flats
which kailicha is part of for years
police and government have struggled to
get drug trafficking and gang violence
under control
experts doubt that military intervention
can change that
no definitely not it can't it's not a
long-term strategy it's
it's not a this is a response it's like
having an
ambulance to pick up a patient it
doesn't it's a response to something
that
terrible that's happened but it's not a
solution to those things happening again
um what the military intervention can do
potentially is to to to create a safe
space temporarily
where other effective strategies can be
put in place but it provides an
opportunity and an and a
window for things to happen that are
potentially going to be effective and
sustainable in the long run
tabisso lander is also hoping for more
long-term
he wants to show us his house in
kailicha more precisely his small
private garden
he'd like to earn more money with
agriculture but there's no space
the township is growing daily people
need places to stay
people took everything out all the
vegetation unfortunately
in the field houses wants to continue
anyway
and he wants to show his son how to
garden so he doesn't end up getting
involved with gangs
like his father for example
the johannesburg inner city has been
rocked by two weeks of violence
angry mobs looting and destroying
anything in their path with
foreign-owned businesses clearing the
brunt
of their anger there is nothing that has
sparked
any form of this conflict between south
africans
and the foreign nationals so that we're
dealing with criminality rather than
xenophobia at the present moment
whatever it is the effect has been
devastating
on mabunang an inner city hub for
tourism
culture cuisine and entrepreneurship
this is what the damage looks like and
there's a big crowd of people just
throwing stones bricks businesses have
seen a significant drop
in visitors since the unrest began
putting serious pressure on the
hospitality
and tourism sectors which rely on the
city's estimated
5 million annual visitors
how are we going to sustain these two
industries with through the chaos
that always worries me that always
stresses me out
police have increased their numbers on
the ground
conducting raids and patrols across
johannesburg
we want to make sure that what happened
last time
where people were looting shops it
doesn't happen
again or it doesn't spread to other
areas we will be remaining in all the
hot spots
or in all the areas that we affected
until we are sure that everything is
back to normal analysts argue
the damage is already done this city is
the
most unequal in the world and it took a
long time to begin to get
people in the middle class to go and say
eat on sidewalks
at restaurants and go out in the town
and this definitely
is a psychological barrier to continuing
the reintegration of class and race in
our awfully divided cities
it's a tragedy and it's not only
restaurants
hostels bars and hotels feeling the
pinch
inner city commerce is taking a serious
hit
i just have this feeling they might come
back my customers
are scared they've been calling me they
cannot come and collect their stuff
some of their stuff has been damaged so
bubbling is never going to be the same
again
although authorities claim the situation
is slowly normalizing
the unrest has already cost 12 lives
and the city of gold remains on edge